It's the
holiday shopping season,
and if you're having
some financial excited, you're all right.
Experts say that this is normal,
especially about buying gifts
and deciding
how much money
to spend on friends and family.
Here to help us is Michelle Singletary.
She's a personal finance
columnist for The Washington Post.
She's also the author
of What to Do With Your Money
When Crisis Hits a Survival Guide.
Michelle, good to see you again.
Let me talk to you about this
hundred dollar budget for gifts.
Now, this excludes food for the big meal,
but Michelle,
$100 for everybody.
Everybody.
And happy holiday to you.
And yes, $100.
That's right.
It's based on this book, A $100 Holiday
by Bill McKibben.
And basically
what you're going to do is just you
first of all,
you have a smaller list, right?
And then you just got to really think
about the kinds of things
that people want.
Like,
how often
are you looking for a charge
for your phone?
Right.
You know,
just like that little small thing.
And you want one for your car
and your dad.
You always want these things like that.
And then the other way you can do
that is think of alternative gift giving.
Like one year
my daughter gave me three
home cooked meals
and I can invite to guess.
So you grew up in D.C.?
I can make you one of those guys.
I'll be there.
All right.
I love it.
And so
and then one
person wrote me and said
she told her mom, listen,
I'm trying to save some money.
What is it that you want?
And she said,
you know what she said, Time, baby.
And so she said,
How about if I help you declutter
your house,
that you've been talking about that?
And the mom said, yes,
because that meant several hours
with your adult child, because,
you know,
they only want to spend
about 5 minutes with you.
And so that means going through photos
and things like that.
I mean,
and grandparents can take on their phone
because grandparents
got their phones, too,
are reading their
their grandkids favorite story, you know,
and then the parents can play it for them
if they're out of town at bedtime.
It's about realizing that
what we mostly want from
folks is time and presence
and that the present.
So I also could go
for some metro collar stays,
which aren't expensive,
but I can never find a matching pair
when I need them.
So there are some things on the list.
But you're talking about all adults here.
What about the key to being good all year
and expecting Santa
to make it rain on the 25th?
And you are at a $100 budget and Santa
might be on your plan too.
Well, you know,
in the
way we're talking about people
who are probably struggling. Right.
And you manage
your children's expectations.
You know, we always did that.
My husband that without children
we go, you know what?
Sanders had a difficult time.
He you know, some elves
didn't show up for work,
so we don't know what
else.
All right.
Oh, my.
They're trying to unionize.
So we say, come on, bring your list.
But you're only going to get about two
or three days off.
Two or three things off the list.
And when they were little.
I know you don't.
You don't fall off to sleep
when I tell you this,
when they were little, like under three,
I would look through their closet
and their toy bed and find things
that they hadn't been playing with.
Or maybe they got a gift
that they didn't
really particularly care.
And I wrapped it up
and put it under the tree.
Yes, I think. Yes, yes, yes.
That's a good thing.
The kids love unwrapping stuff.
That's what they really like. Right.
And they usually only like
one or two things anyway.
And so that gives them
the ability to unwrap stuff
and have that fun.
And you don't have to spend
a lot of money.
And your kids
must have horrible memories
that they already had this
like three days ago. But okay,
so this is a
good segue
way, though, into your
your piece on regifting.
You give seven tips here,
and I don't think I've ever read
gifted anything.
I have a person in my life
who, for probably the last ten years
has given me a gift every year.
And I immediately put it in my car
because when I stop by goodwill,
I want to make sure I donate it
because it's never anything I use.
But they
and they are adamant
about giving me something.
If you agree gift, go ahead.
So what?
I love that
you're donating that and that's great.
You can. Yeah.
You know, raise money for charity, help
somebody out.
But like,
say when you're a working person
and you're living paycheck to paycheck
and you go to a party
for you or your child
and you get something
and it's not what the child likes.
People used to give my son
trucks and stuff like that,
but my son read he would love books
and so he wouldn't care about that.
So some of you donated some of it.
I have a regifting closet
and you put those in there and you've got
you know,
when they're little,
they got all these birthday parties
and one of his friends loves Trump.
And so you're like,
okay, I got a truck
and a kid who like to truck
and you rewrap it
and give it to that kid.
It's just being creative.
And listen, we get so much stuff.
We have so much stuff
in our homes, in our lives.
It would help the environment,
you know, take the stress off,
always try to find something.
Then the kids that we give to
is to give something
that a person would like.
You know, you know,
if my best friend's a delta,
I'll give her a pink Christmas.
Somebody better. Not.
Like so.
But, you know, if
you've got a pair of earrings
that you like,
you know, your best friend
would like that, it's okay.
And we don't have to tell people
what we got these give it.
And I'm not saying
you're going to give everything
that you give to everybody.
But you know, there have been times
that you've invited to something
at the last minute.
It's a birthday party or something,
and you don't have time to shop,
but you have something in your closet
that's new. It has to be new.
All the parts have to be there
and it's okay.
So then we gift that to that person.
Now, listen, I have a
I have a rule don't ask, don't tell.
Now, if you suspect somebody
gave you a gift, right,
don't embarrass them. Right.
You're a great receiver.
I have. Right.
And if you want the gift,
they don't put it in,
you know, a sex box
when you bought it at Costco, right?
Yeah, that's true.
That's a good thing, is don't
try to fool somebody.
I have received
many scented candles that I know.
People didn't go to the store
and buy themselves.
Michelle Singletary
of The Washington Post,
always good to have you on.
Thanks so much.
Wilson.
I don't have time
and I want to get a gift
from your region for you
and you know where I live.
All right. I will.
All right myself. I'll be back.